Guten Morgen, Linus.
Guten Morgen, Tim.
Ich glaube, bei der Internetsituation hat sich immer noch nichts geändert.
Kein Wunder, wenn die Daten-Elche alle in Österreich unterwegs sind.
Logbuch Netzpolitik Nummer 531 vom, was haben wir denn heute?
Siebter.
Siebter, neunter, 25.
Moment mal, es ist Union Spieltag und du kennst das Datum nicht?
Ich muss es doch ein bisschen verleugnen, ne?
Nimmt hier im Union Outfit an und weiß dann nicht mal, was für ein Tag ist.
Doch, heute ist historischer Spieltag heute.
Ich weiß das wohl Wieso?
Erstes Spiel der Frauenmannschaft vom 1. FC Union Berlin in der 1. Bundesliga der Frauen.
Von vielen, die noch folgen werden.
Ja. Das wird toll.
Da bin ich mir sicher.
Genau. Heute machen wir eine Fußball-Sendung, haben wir mal beschlossen.
Weil netzpolitisch ist ja nichts passiert.
Surprise! Naja, stimmt gar nicht. Also, kleiner Nachtrag zur letzten Sendung.
Ich hatte ja gerätselt, wo dieser Eintrag in meinem Kalender herkam.
Ja.
Und ja, der kam tatsächlich aus LNP und die Frage war, hat sich was an der Internetsituation
geändert? Jetzt wissen wir warum.
Es hat sich nichts geändert, weil die Elche laufen jetzt in Österreich rum. Emil.
Emil ist der Daten-Elch für E-Mail.
E-Mail immer so langsam ist. Ja, Emil. Du hast von der E-Mail gar nichts mitbekommen, ne?
Nee, ich war nicht in Österreich.
E-Mail läuft einfach durch Österreich seit Tagen und Wochen und irgendwie kriegen
den jetzt nicht so richtig eingefangen, weil so ein Elch ist auch jetzt,
sagen wir mal, nicht so einfach einzufangen.
So ein junger Elch.
Wie ist der denn da hingekommen? Wegen GPS-Jamming?
Kann sein. Ja, wahrscheinlich hat er nur ein GPS installiert und kein Galileo.
Man habe versucht, Emil zum Weitergehen zu bewegen, aber das war nicht,
der hat sich von der Lokomotive nicht beeindrucken lassen.
Ja.
Okay.
Genau.
Ja, okay.
Drei Jahre alt. Oh, wenn der S3 ist, wie alt wird so ein Elch?
Also der könnte den längere Zeit da Schwierigkeiten machen.
Genau, während Brandenburg weiterhin unterversorgt ist. Das ist das Problem. Wo kam der jetzt her?
Aus Tschechien?
Ja, weiß man nicht so ganz genau, aber es gibt da Siedlungsgebiete von Elchen.
Aber es ist wohl sehr ungewöhnlich, dass der den Weg dahin gefunden hat.
Und jetzt trabt er halt durch diese urbanen Gegenden und weiß nicht so richtig, wo er hin soll.
Und Sie gehen davon aus, dass er auch schon in der Donau schwimmen war.
Das heißt, ihm gefällt es da.
Ja, offensichtlich. Also...
Also mehr E-Mail für Österreich, weniger für uns.
Aber E-Mail, das ist auch so ein Teil des Internets, den können wir gerne wegnehmen.
Ja, da träumst du von, dass das passieren wird.
Ja, D-Mail, das machen wir demnächst alles mit D-Mail dann.
Wir wollen noch ganz kurz auf die Adenauer-Tour hinweisen, die gestern auf dem
Tempelhofer Feld in Berlin ihren Auftakt hatte.
Ja.
War ganz nett. Der Cornerchor war da, der
dieses schöne Lied bei dem Alice Weidel-Sommerinterview beigesteuert hat.
Er hat das live dort vorgesungen.
War das vor oder nachdem ich da war?
Ich glaube vorher. Um 15 Uhr ungefähr war das. Du warst etwas später da, ne?
Ja, hab ich verpasst.
Dann kam noch Team Scheiße. Fand ich aber nicht so gut.
Fand ich scheiße. Nee, also Team Scheiße war da. Sebastian Krummbiegel und so weiter.
Und man kann den Adenauer in seine Stadt und vor allem in seine Schule bestellen.
Bestelle den Adenauer SAP Plus jetzt in deine Schule.
Das finde ich gut. Oder kann es Projektwochen veranstalten.
Wir haben ja vielleicht die eine oder andere Lehrerin und Lehrer unter unseren Hörerinnen.
Da könnt ihr euch einen schönen Bus bestellen. Ob Team Scheiße mit dabei ist,
weiß ich nicht. Der steht hier wahrscheinlich dann im Kleingedruckten. Aber ja.
War lustig. Schöner Sonntag.
Genau, also der Bus, sehr beeindruckend. Ich habe jetzt mal so richtig aus der
Nähe gesehen in seiner aktuellen Ausbaustufe mit all diesen ganzen Applikationen und Lautsprechern.
Es ist einfach unfassbar, wie laut das Ding ist.
Aber mir wurde mehrfach bekräftigt, dass so wie er da jetzt auf dem Tempelhoferfeld eingesetzt wurde.
Nicht ansatzweise, dass das Lautsprechpotenzial ausgeschöpft hat.
Aber es ist schon cool, wenn man so einen Bus hat, den stellt man irgendwo hin
und es ist einfach sofort Rave-kompatibel. Also da fehlt halt irgendwie nix.
Der ist Rave-kompatibel.
Geil, so einen Bus brauche ich auch.
Schön jetzt auch mit Bassanhänger, also die Lautsprecher auf dem Ding,
die ja gereicht haben für diese Sommerinterview-Geschichte und die wirklich enorm laut sind.
Ja, also ich war da vor einiger Zeit bei einem Test auf einem sehr großen freien
Feld und die Leute, die die Soundanlage quasi eingestellt haben,
haben so diese Ordenschützer getragen, immer wenn sie sich dem Ding genähert
haben, um dann irgendwie an der Anlage zu fuchteln und dann wieder bei sich
20, 30 Meter wegzugehen in den nicht mehr körperverletzend lauten Bereich.
Also das Ding ist, das ist eine Anlage, die ist in Ordnung.
Alright.
Sehr schön. Genau, mal schauen, wo, also diese Tour, die Tour fängt jetzt an,
man kann den quasi anfragen,
auch in seine Stadt und dann wird er den Wahlkampf in NRW, hat er natürlich jetzt vor sich und ja,
Stefan sagt ja so, weißt du, wenn du jetzt irgendwo in irgendeiner kleineren
Stadt Erfurt, Erfurt zum Beispiel, um dann nochmal bei Team Scheiße zu bleiben,
eine Demonstration oder eine Aktion gegen die AfD machst, dann hast du ja vielleicht
mitunter so ein bisschen Schwierigkeiten der Mobilisierung oder auch,
dass da eine ausreichende Berichterstattung über deine demokratische Aktion da stattfindet.
Und da macht der Adenauer natürlich direkt einen ganz anderen Eindruck,
den er dahinter lässt, ne?
Und genau dafür ist er ja da. Dafür wurde er ja gebaut.
Und das finde ich super schön. Da freue ich mich drauf und drüber,
dass das jetzt hier so ganz deutschlandweit diese Tour geben wird und dass sie
damit immer weitermachen. Und das ist einfach eine super schöne Sache.
Ja, ist verlinkt.
Gut, kommen wir zum Feedback. Wie schon eingangs angedeutet,
wurde natürlich darauf hingewiesen, dass es ja ganz einfach ist rauszufinden,
wann ich diesen Eintrag in diesen Kalender gemacht habe und es ist tatsächlich drei Jahre her.
LNP 437, Karotte am Stick.
Hätte ich auch selber schnell rausfinden können, mir wurde gleich technisch
erklärt, wie ich das machen kann und natürlich steht im Kalender auch ein Erzeugungsdatum
und das hätte ich auch ganz einfach finden können.
Aber ich bin ja alt und habe keine Ahnung mehr und deswegen vielen Dank an Lord
Sexy und an Tim mit Doppel-M, die mich da entsprechend zurechtgewiesen haben.
Uwe S. fügt dann noch an, also mag ja sein, dass bei euch in Berlin sich nichts
getan hat, weil war ja schon immer jemand auf hohem Niveau, aber hier in unserer
ländlichen Region wurde vor drei Jahren Glasfaser kostenlos in jedes Haus gelegt,
wo vorher kleiner 25 Megabit Anlagen.
Kann natürlich sein, dass man bei euch in Berlin inzwischen damit überholt hat,
da ihr ja dann euren Vermieter dazwischen habt, der das Glas nicht bis in die Wohnung legen will.
Genau, das ist ein Aspekt. Hier ist meist der Eigentümer auch der Nutzer vom Gebäude.
Wir können halt nicht klagen, da ihr faktisch jede Milch keine Glasfaser bekommen
habt, wenn sich der Eigentümer gemeldet hat.
Ja, also das mag es natürlich sein, dass sich stellenweise irgendwo was tut,
aber ich denke mal so insgesamt kann man schon festhalten, hat sich so an der
Internetsituation generell so im Großen und Ganzen nicht so viel geändert.
Also ich glaube, ich habe auch Glasfaser in der Wohnung liegen.
Das war eine Änderung, die stattgefunden hat.
Und ich glaube, du musst einfach mal irgendwann deinen komischen Autovertrag da...
Das hat ja mit meinem Mobilfunkvertrag nichts zu tun.
Es gibt halt einfach nach wie vor sehr viele Orte, die klagen,
dass sie halt einfach nicht angeschlossen werden, weil sich das dann einfach eben nicht ergibt.
Könnte noch schneller gehen. Aber man muss schon wahrscheinlich,
also in den letzten drei Jahren haben ein paar Leute Glasfaser bekommen.
Das ist eine Veränderung.
Das wäre ja jetzt auch schlimm gewesen, wenn nicht. Also ein bisschen was muss ich ja schon tun.
Wir hatten ja dann auch diese schöne Geschichte mit dem fehlenden Funkmast,
wo der da abgerissen werden musste und dann nicht richtig ersetzt wurde.
Matthias weist uns noch auf eine Geschichte im Hamburger Ortsteil Klein Borstel hin.
Die haben auch schlechte Netzabdeckung, weil natürlich irgendeine Initiative,
Sendemastfreies Klein Borstel einen existierenden Funkmast wieder hat deinstallieren
lassen, wegen der bösen Strahlung.
Genau. Wegen möglicher Gesundheitsrisiken.
Geil.
Das ist wirklich super, oder? Also Leute, wirklich echt.
Habt ihr schon mal was von Licht gehört? Ja, Licht ist eigentlich überall und so.
Das ist sowas ähnliches.
Ja, ich bin also, Tim, ich glaube, der Vergleich, also nicht alles,
was hinkt, ist ein Vergleich, weil auch Licht mitunter schädlich sein kann.
Also bevor die jetzt da alle demnächst mit einem Sonnenbrand kommen und sagen
hier, den habe ich von dem Sendemasten.
Funk-Sonnenbrand.
Ich gebe denen keine guten Ideen.
Datenbrand. Ich habe einen Datenbrand.
Oh Mann, echt. Viel zu viel Daten hier in der Luft.
Da brauchst du Datenschutzfaktor 30.
Schreit schreit schreit schreit,
schreit,
Oh Gott. Ja, okay. Jetzt wissen wir ja, also womit wir uns da Geld verdienen
können in der nächsten Zeit.
Da kannst du viel Geld mit Datenschutzmitteln kannst du Ja. Ja, okay.
Gut, machen wir mal weiter mit Ernsthaft.
Datenbrandkrieg mit Datenschutzfaktor 30.
So bei Vero hast du auch falsch gelegen.
Also, bei Vero, naja, also, Christian sagt, eigentlich finde ich es ja immer
ganz angenehm, wenn Linus und Tim klar sagen, dass sie keine Experten sind und sich zurückhalten.
Haben wir sowas schon mal gesagt? Bei Vero haben sie ganz schön versagt.
Grumpy Old Men können ja witzig sein, aber so richtig schlecht vorbereitet zu
ranten, wirkt dann eher traurig.
Also wir stellen fest, Christian arbeitet für Vero. Was ist falsch?
Was haben wir falsch beschrieben?
Ja, weiß ich nicht. Vero macht angeblich vieles richtiger als GiroPay,
was ja irgendwie auf 0,4% Verbreitung kam so in Deutschland.
In Deutschland sind deutlich mehr Banken als nur die Sparkassen dabei und auch
in anderen europäischen Ländern gibt es rege Beteiligungen, die teilweise mit
einem Übergang von anderen nationalen Systemen wie Ideal in Niederlanden in Vero einhergehen.
Ja, er fügt noch hinzu und zu den Themen Souveränität, man kann zum Beispiel
keine kubanischen Zigarren per Paypal bezahlen, weil wir uns jetzt auch an amerikanische
Sanktionen halten müssen, die es in Europa eigentlich nicht gibt.
Wenn es der Orange gefällt, stellt er halt Paypal und die Kreditkarten einfach ab.
Also ganz kurz dazu.
Richtig, aber ich glaube, dass es eine, vielleicht kurz dazu,
wir haben ja auch, ich glaube da gab es auch schon Logbuch-Netzpolitik,
haben wir wahrscheinlich auch damals darüber berichtet,
dass es eine Zahlungsblockade gegen Wikileaks gab.
Die übrigens nicht nur bei Paypal, sondern auch bei Visa und Mastercard gegriffen hat.
Die verhindert haben, dass Spenden an Wikileaks stattfinden konnten.
Was historisch auch nochmal die Rolle der Wau-Holland-Stiftung,
also der Stiftung um den Gründer des Chaos Computer Clubs,
gestärkt hat in der Spenden, Entgegennahme und Verwaltung für Wikileaks.
Das ist erstmal alles richtig, aber dazu haben wir ja eigentlich,
also darüber haben wir ja relativ wenig gesprochen.
Also wir haben ja nicht gesagt, dass PayPal jetzt irgendwie Souveränität bieten
würde, sondern dass PayPal seit inzwischen weiß nicht, was waren das jetzt,
zweieinhalb, annähernd drei Jahrzehnten einen,
einen de facto Standard in Usability ohne Konkurrenz bietet.
Jetzt bin ich mal gespannt, wie Vero das besser macht oder mit dem konkurrieren kann.
Ja, das ist schwierig, weil also die Behauptung, da würden jetzt deutlich mehr
Banken als nur die Sparkassen dabei sind. so, ja, stimmt.
Also da sind halt die Sparkassen, die Volksbanken und Reifeisenbanken,
die Postbank, GLS, ING und dann noch irgendwie so fünf. Und das war's.
Also last time I checked, haben wir deutlich mehr Banken in Deutschland.
Mit anderen Worten, dass es hier bestenfalls, wenn man die Sparkassenbrille
auf hat, kann man hier von Verbreitung sprechen.
Aber für die allermeisten Banken gilt das halt nicht.
Also das ist halt noch lange nicht so weit, dass da von einer nennenswerten
Verbreitung geredet werden kann.
Also meine Banken sind da weitgehend nicht dabei.
Bisschen Sparda und so weiter.
So, dann ist ja diese ganze Benutzung von diesem Teil ist ja auch schwierig.
Ich habe mir das mal runtergeladen, dann musst du dann halt irgendwie immer
wieder indirekt über deine Banking-App gehen und wie geil die Banking-Apps in
Deutschland sind, das wissen wir ja alle.
Es gibt halt keinen wirklich einen internetwebbasierten Control des Ganzen,
weil das letzten Endes ja nur so ein aufgeflanschtes Interface ist für die Banken.
Also es ist so ein bisschen der Versuch, hier in irgendeiner Form so eine Internet,
Vereinheitlichung zu haben oder über eine App vielmehr und,
ich finde das halt einfach in seiner ganzen Lösung her nach wie vor sehr,
sehr, sehr clumsy und da ist halt einfach mal Paypal, ich meine,
ich bin weit davon entfernt, Paypal zuerst,
Zoll zu finden oder Paypal jetzt hier irgendwie zu,
zu featuren. Es ist einfach nur de facto ist es halt einfach da und es hat einfach
das Problem im Netz zu bezahlen, als es kam und Paypal gibt es schon sehr lange.
Ich weiß nicht, wann sind die gegründet worden? 99 oder so?
Wir hatten es in der letzten Sendung herausgefunden.
Wir hatten es schon rausgefunden, aber es ist auf jeden Fall schon 98 genau.
98, muss man was ich mir mal vorstellen.
27 Jahre.
Und jetzt kommen sie langsam so auf die Ideen, man müsste ja mal was machen.
Hurra kann ich dazu nur sagen.
Und erstens, Vero gibt es seit Juli 2024 Zahlungsbegrenzung auf 1000 Euro.
Das heißt, größere Sachen kannst du damit eh nicht kaufen. Und es gibt es derzeit
nur in Belgien, Deutschland und Frankreich und dann nur mit einzelnen Banken.
Und Niederlande und so weiter, das kommt jetzt eigentlich erst noch.
Und Luxemburg, Also Benelux.
Und sie träumen davon, in zwei, drei Jahren irgendwie die ganze EU abgedeckt zu haben.
Also weckt mich, wenn es soweit ist, aber ich habe da ehrlich gesagt meine Probleme
und vor allem, was ich hier halt sehe ist,
so wie das vorangeht, wird es sehr viel Widerstand weiterhin haben von irgendwelchen
Banken, die alle noch in irgendeiner Form irgendeine Anbindung dafür machen müssen.
Und das ist halt dann einfach so Design by Committee und das wird einfach nicht durchstarten.
Davon abgesehen ist es ja eh offensichtlich, dass wir mittlerweile.
Also es siegt immer die Convenience und deswegen nehmen die Leute PayPal auch, wenn es teurer ist.
Ich meine es halt einfach verbreitet, weil es halt einfach einfacher ist.
Und genauso ist es jetzt mit den ganzen gerätebasierten Authentifizierungssystemen
Apple Pay, Google Pay, die gewinnen
halt einfach, weil sie auf den Geräten sind, mit denen bezahlt wird.
Und das sind eigentlich die neuen Gatekeeper und da wird ein Vero sich auch
nicht irgendwie reindrücken können.
Selbst Paypal muss da jetzt mitspielen.
Also die, man muss ja hier noch,
also Fabian hat auf Ewa Mastodon auch kommentiert, Ich kann Menschen kostenlos
Geld schicken, braucht dafür lediglich ihre Handynummer oder ihre E-Mail-Adresse,
also Daten, die ich bereits in meinem Adressbuch habe.
Kostenlos und soll europaweit sein, ist kein Schlandalleingang.
Dingens hier, der orangefarbene Verrückte hat keinen Zugang.
Und das sind ja erstmal...
Technische Argumente, die dieses System beschreiben.
Und ich glaube, das ist halt der Kritikpunkt, den Fabian und Christian unterbringen,
dass wir im Prinzip das Urteil machen, wir kennen dieses System nicht, also ist es lächerlich.
Während sie beide einfordern, dass wir uns wenigstens mal mit der technischen
Basis auseinandersetzen.
Was wir in der letzten Sendung ja auch ein bisschen, worüber wir ja gelacht
haben, ist, dass es halt 27 Jahre gedauert hat, bis sie überhaupt mal versuchen,
in Konkurrenz zu treten.
Und dass vermutlich die Banken, wenn man sich dazu überlegt,
dass die ja die Kundenbeziehungen unterhalten.
Man ihnen auch vielleicht gönnen würde, auf dieser Basis etwas zu machen.
Also ich meine, PayPal geht hin und hat gar nichts. Die haben einfach nur ein
Start-up und sagen, hier, meld dich an, wir machen Geld. Fertig, läuft.
Dann kommen, und Banken haben das Geld ja schon.
Also die haben sich da ja schon vor 27 Jahren die Butter vom Brot nehmen lassen.
Dann kommt Apple und Google hin und sagen, übrigens, wir haben diese Geräte
und wir bauen jetzt darauf Paymentsysteme auf.
Apple Pay, Google Pay, hast du alles nicht gesehen. Zack, läuft wieder.
Banken immer noch da und denken, what the fuck, irgendwie, keine Ahnung,
kommen wir hier nicht hinterher.
Und das ist ja auch nochmal der Punkt bei diesem PayPal-Vorfall,
den wir in der letzten Sendung nicht so ordentlich beschrieben haben.
Dadurch, dass PayPal ja ein zentralisiertes System ist, können die die Kohle
relativ gefahrlos von einem Account in den anderen schicken.
Also wenn jetzt was weiß ich, ich über PayPal Geld an Tim schicke oder jemand
mein PayPal hackt und das an Tim schickt, dann ist es in der nächsten Sekunde
Tims Account gut geschrieben. Und das ist ja auch, das ist die Stärke von PayPal.
Wenn Tim das Geld da raustragen will, dann wird PayPal auf einmal langsam.
Oh ja, das dauert aber jetzt drei, vier Tage, bis wir dir das Geld schicken.
Letztendlich einfach nur, weil sie warten, ob es noch irgendwelche Fraud-Claims oder sowas gibt.
Und da outsourcen sie auf einmal bei diesem Bankeinzug letztendlich ihre Geldsicherheitsdinger
an die deutschen Banken.
Und das ist schon so ein Punkt.
Gleichzeitig, ja, es sei uns doch bitte erlaubt, darüber zu lachen,
dass die deutschen Banken nach 27 Jahren auch noch mal versuchen,
irgendwie da mitzuspielen.
Was halt, ja, diese Hilflosigkeit zeigt und du hast ja gerade gesagt,
ja, Design by Committee, ja klar, da versuchen irgendwelche Leute einen Standard zu machen.
Ich glaube, die sind dafür nicht richtig aufgestellt. Also ich glaube,
es ist, sie müssten halt anders denken.
Ja und ich meine das Argument mit Überweisung innerhalb der Bank geht schnell,
gilt auch für jede Bank in Deutschland in der Regel.
Also ich meine war vielleicht auch nicht unbedingt immer so,
aber das ist zumindest meistens so, weil die können von einem Konto aufs andere natürlich überweisen.
Ansonsten hattest du lange Zeit immer noch dieses Problem, dass auch eine normale
Überweisung einen Werktag gebraucht hat, weil sie das halt in diesen Badges.
Machen. Dann kamen Sofortüberweisungen.
Was hat die Sparkasse als erstes gemacht?
Gebühren für eine Sofortüberweisung. Also man sollte ja dann dafür zahlen,
dass es schneller geht. Ich meine, mit dieser Einstellung wird das nichts.
Jetzt jubeln alle, dass es Sofortüberweisungen gibt und dass es jetzt auch kostenlos
ist, weil die Banken eingesehen haben, dass es Quatsch ist, da auch noch Geld für zu nehmen.
Die haben das ja so als Feature angesehen, während andere Leute gesagt haben,
wieso war das nicht schon immer so?
Und sich einen Bugfix bezahlen zu lassen, ist halt auch irgendwie frech.
Und diese Mentalität, die begrenzt das einfach so. Da ist einfach keinerlei Speed zu erwarten.
Und ich habe überhaupt nichts gegen eine Standardisierung und ich finde,
das sollte auch auf einer europäischen Ebene geregelt werden.
Das SEPA-System, was an sich erstmal ganz gut funktioniert, da auch eine Internetschnittstelle bekommt.
Aber das könnte man sozusagen auch auf SEPA-Ebene selbst regeln.
Ich möchte noch ganz kurz den Begriff Sofortüberweisung, müssen wir glaube ich
auch noch mal kurz eine Begriffsschärfung machen.
Es gibt jetzt, also warum dauern Überweisungen mindestens einen Werktag?
Weil die ganzen Transaktionen einmal am Ende des Tages gebündelt werden und
dann zählen die Banken einfach einmal unter sich große Geldbeträge.
Also das wird nicht jede einzelne Überweisung, findet statt,
sondern am Ende des Tages sagen die Banken, wir schicken, weil sich die DKB
schickt jetzt 100.000 an die GLS Bank oder was auch immer, wie diese Banken heißen, Sparkasse.
Und weil damit diese Wertschreibung, die kann dann wiederum übrigens an dem
richtigen Tag liegen, aber dass der Geldbetrag erscheint, ist eben erst nach diesem Settlement.
Warte mal, heißt das Settlement oder Clearing? Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher,
eins von beiden. Aber quasi, dass die Banken zwischen sich die Balances ausgleichen.
Und dann haben die Sofortüberweisung, du erinnerst dich, das,
ist Klana, die hatten, das war so ein Angebot, was übrigens auch sehr viele
Leute verwendet haben, wo du diesem Anbieter Zugang zu deinem Konto gibst.
Weißt du, da musstest du irgendwie dein Passwort, dein Online-Banking-Passwort eingeben.
Und dann haben die irgendwie deinen Kontostand gesehen, um zu gucken,
ob du diese Überweisung machen kannst und dann eine Lastschrift ich weiß gar
nicht, ich hab das nie gemacht, das war völlig irrsinnig, so irgendwie Hallo,
wir sind Sofortüberweisung.de, gib mal bitte dein Banking-Passwort ein.
An der Stelle habe ich immer abgebrochen.
Aber auch das war ein Thing.
Also das gab es hier. Das haben auch bestimmt wahrscheinlich Menschen genutzt,
sonst würde diese Firma ja nicht mehr existieren. völlig irre.
Und jetzt haben sie irgendwie da rangeflanscht, irgendwie dieses Echtzeitüberweisung
oder Sofortüberweisungsding.
Entschuldigung, da war ich jetzt etwas unklar. Also ich habe jetzt den Begriff
Sofortüberweisung, der tatsächlich von dem Unternehmen klar nah geprägt wurde.
Was ich damit meinte, ist die SEPA Instant Payment, also die Echtzeitüberweisung.
Und die gibt es jetzt auch, Wo du nämlich in deiner Banking-App unter Anwendung eines Standards,
den jetzt alle unterstützen oder bald alle unterstützen, per EU-Verordnung ab
Januar 2025, müssen das alle machen, also zumindest empfangen können.
Im Oktober müssen sie alle auch versenden können.
Ah ja, genau. Und jetzt ist aber eigentlich die Frage.
Vor dem Hintergrund, dass PayPal sagt, okay, wir machen eine Sofortwertstellung,
das Geld ist sofort weg, bleibt aber in unserem Hoheitsbereich.
Und wenn du jetzt über PayPal was schickst und dann kommt irgendwie drei Tage
später, stellt sich raus,
das war jetzt fraudulent, aus welchem Grund auch immer, dein PayPal-Account
wurde gehackt oder was auch immer, dann bis dahin ist das Geld von,
zumindest hat das nicht das PayPal-Ökosystem verlassen.
Du kannst zwar Echtzeit von PayPal zu PayPal überweisen, aber eben nicht Echtzeit
von PayPal auf ein Bankkonto.
Und diese Echtzeitüberweisung trägt ein höheres Risiko, nicht im Interesse der Nutzerinnen zu sein.
Weißt du, wenn ich es schaffe, einen Account zu übernehmen und dann irgendwie
eine Echtzeitüberweisung in großer Summe tätige und das Geld ist halt dann bei
einer anderen Bank und dann mache ich von dort aus es wieder zu einer anderen Bank,
dann ist quasi so dieser Fraudschutz dort nicht so nachvollziehbar stabil,
wie es irgendwie bei PayPal ist, bei einem zentralisierten System,
wo es nämlich letztendlich eine Echtzeitüberweisung innerhalb einer Bank ist. Weißt du?
Diesen architektonischen Unterschied muss man ja zumindest mal hier zur Kenntnis
nehmen. Deswegen weiß ich, ich
weiß gar nicht, ob ich das so gut finde mit dieser Echtzeitüberweisung.
Na, ich finde da jetzt erstmal nichts falsch dran. Übrigens gibt es das mittlerweile auch bei PayPal.
Also du kannst auch bei PayPal eine Echtzeitüberweisung machen,
aber dann wollen sie irgendwie ein Prozent von dem Überweisungsbetrag dafür haben.
Oder mindestens 25 Cent.
Damit covern sie dann ihr Fraudrisiko wahrscheinlich.
Ja, was weiß ich also es ist genauso oder sie.
Nehmen das Geld einfach so.
Es ist egal, was du machst ich finde einfach trotzdem ich mag SEPA,
ich möchte gerne, dass SEPA besser wird, ich möchte gerne mehr so Innovationen
wie Echtzeitüberweisung und auch gerne eine,
Internetschnittstelle muss es denn alles immer nochmal 20 Jahre dauern bis da
was auf die Kette bekommen wird. Naja, egal.
Also hast du dich jetzt bei Vero angemeldet? Die Frage ist, wann Ben an die Meta geben?
Ich kann mich bei Vero nicht anmelden, weil meine Bank das nicht unterstützt.
Ja, musst du zu einer anderen Bank gehen?
Ja, wegen Vero gehe ich jetzt zu einer anderen Bank. Vielleicht habe ich irgendeine
Bank in meinem Portfolio, die das auch unterstützt.
Aber ehrlich gesagt, ich will nicht mit diesen Banking-Apps arbeiten.
Ich benutze nur Banken, die mit Money Money funktionieren, damit ich mit keiner
einzigen App mehr zu tun habe, als vielleicht mal ein Login zu bestätigen oder so.
Nun, lass uns fortfahren.
Auf jeden Fall in Englisch ist diese Seite, nun hat die noch ein bisschen Typos.
Ich will Vero haben jetzt hier.
Ich steige jetzt um. Ich mache jetzt alles nur noch mit Vero.
Mir ist egal, wo ich denn nicht hinbezahlen kann. Dann kriege ich eben kein Geld mehr.
So, weiteres Feedback gab es von D-Rion. Tamagotchi kommt wieder,
offensichtlich. Sagt zumindest die Tagesschau.
Und die Tagesschau sagt, dass Tamagotchi kehrt zurück mit großem farbigen Display.
Und offensichtlich die Firma Bandai hat damit einigen Erfolg. Wer hätte es gedacht?
Zeit für eine T-Shirt-Neuauflage? Kann ich mal drüber nachdenken.
Ich fand das T-Shirt immer geil. Wenn jetzt Tamagotchi wieder bekannt wird,
dann ist das vielleicht auch ganz witzig wieder.
Nokia hat glaube ich auch ein 3310 kannst du jetzt auch wieder,
3210 oder sowas kannst du alles kaufen.
Es ist Retro-Time.
Ja, es ist Retro-Time. Also vor allem ist es ja jetzt so,
hat meine Mutter immer früher drüber gescherzt, als sie ungefähr so in meinem
Alter war oder ein bisschen älter, dass sie quasi ihre Klamotten von vor 20,
30 Jahren wieder anziehen konnte.
Und dass es sich quasi gelohnt hat und dass die natürlich dann auch hohen Wert
hatten, weil das jetzt der echte 70s Shit war so ungefähr.
Das wird halt so mit meinem Tamagotchi sein, was ich ja und was meinst du,
was ich das gepflegt habe über die Jahrzehnte.
Das lebt noch. Ja sicher, sonst wird das doch traurig.
Ich finde das immer bemerkenswert, wenn Leute 30 Jahre alte Klamotten haben,
die noch nicht komplett auseinandergefallen sind.
Ja, dann ziehst du die halt nicht mehr an.
Aha, na toll. Motten.
Okay, Tamagotchi kommt zurück. Mit Internet oder ohne?
Ist es ein souveränes Tamagotchi oder ist es ein Cloud-Gotschi?
Cloud-Gotschi, ja, keine Ahnung. Davon steht hier natürlich nix.
Also ich fütter nur Open-Source-Tiere.
Ich glaube, das Ding wird kein Internet haben. So, jetzt aber mal hier, Netzpolitik.
Ach so, ja, stimmt, sind wir durch. Das Kartellverfahren.
Wir haben ja in der letzten Sendung noch darüber geredet, gewitzelt,
philosophiert, dass dieses Google-Kartellverfahren einen interessanten Ausgang
haben könnte, der Konsequenzen für Google hat.
Quasi beispielsweise, dass sie Chrome oder Android abgeben müssten.
Wir hatten aber auch schon festgestellt, dass dieses Verfahren eröffnet worden
war von der Biden-Regierung und dass sich seitdem ja etwas in der US-Regierung geändert hat.
Was ist da jetzt rausgekommen? Also welche schwere Strafe hat Google jetzt?
Ja, also auf jeden Fall nicht die Befürchtete.
Also die Richter haben gesagt, eine Abspaltung von Chrome oder Android aus dem
Google-Konzern ist vom Tisch.
Und ja, interessanterweise dürfte gerade das Aufkommen von Perplexity und Konsorten
dazu beigetragen haben,
dass die Einschätzung bezüglich der ewigen Dominanz der Sasuk-Maschine ein wenig
gelitten hat in den Augen der Richter.
Dass sie einfach sagen, so ja nee, also ist uns jetzt mal gar nicht so klar,
dass dieses Suchmaschinenmonopol bestehen bleibt, weil offensichtlich gibt es
ja jetzt einen klaren Trend hin zu diesen AI-Chatbots und ob da jetzt Google
Konkurrenz losbleibt, das sehen wir mal offen.
Insgesamt wird glaube ich Google weitgehend ungeschoren davon kommen,
also es wird zwar jetzt darüber resoniert, dass Google so Daten teilen muss,
die sie quasi aus ihrer Suchmaschine gewinnen, aber inwiefern das dann wirklich
jetzt für andere Unternehmen wirklich ein Nutzen ist, das würde ich sagen ist
mal offen, weil ja dieser ganze Werbemarkt ist ja vor allem so ein Realtime-Markt.
Also es werden ja quasi die Werbung wird ja quasi in Echtzeit auktioniert in
dem Moment, wo Suchanfragen überhaupt erst reinkommen und wenn du dann später
irgendwelche Daten teilst,
dann ist es unter Umständen gar nicht so ein Ding, aber da habe ich nicht so den Einblick.
Es gibt dann Einschränkungen dass sie halt,
bestimmte Dinge dürfen sie halt nicht machen es war ja auch die Frage,
ob dieser Suchmaschinen Default erlaubt sein dürfte das war ja vor allem jetzt für,
potenziell für Apple vielleicht jetzt nicht unbedingt eine Bedrohung,
aber sicherlich für Mozilla das ist weiterhin erlaubt,
die Meinung scheint sich auch bezüglich dieser Choice-Screens ein bisschen geändert
zu haben, weil sich wohl rausgestellt hat, dass das irgendwie keine größere Auswirkungen hat.
Also, dass die Anbieter gezwungen werden zu sagen, so hier, 30 Browser,
von denen du nie was gehört hast, welchen hättest du denn gerne als Default?
Das heißt, diese Deals sind weiterhin erlaubt und die sind ja,
ich glaube, dass es auch bei diesen Verträgen ehrlich gesagt weniger um den
Default geht, sicherlich auch,
sondern mehr eben dann auch über den Traffic, der darüber generiert wird,
deswegen ist das ja alles so wertvoll.
Diese Verträge darf es also weiterhin geben, die müssen allerdings maximal zwölf
Monate gültig sein und dann müssen sie neu ausgehandelt werden,
damit das nicht so ein Ewigkeitsvertrag wird.
Okay, aber also letztendlich nix. Also quasi keine nennenswerte Strafe.
Nee, inwiefern man jetzt bei dieser Richterentscheidung auch schon einen Einfluss
der neuen Regierung sieht, weiß ich nicht, kann ich nicht beurteilen.
Andererseits finde ich das eigentlich auch ganz nachvollziehbar.
Also wenn ich hier irgendetwas nachvollziehbar finde, dann ist es,
dass es sich jetzt nach 20 Jahren Marktdominanz Google doch wieder Konkurrenz hat.
Aber wahrscheinlich hätte man den Frühjahr einfach mal eine Strafe geben sollen.
Gleichermaßen hat Google ja in der EU eine Strafe bekommen, nämlich Verstoß
gegen Wettbewerbregeln im Werbegeschäft.
Strafe 2,95 Milliarden.
Und die Idee dahinter, also die Begründung dieser Strafe ist, Ähm.
Sie hätten also die eigenen Online-Werbedienstleistungen zum Nachteil Konkurrierender bevorzugt.
Also Werbetreibende und den Anbietern von Werbeflätzen wurde insbesondere der
Marktplatz at X bevorzugt vorgeschlagen.
Also wenn du bei Google gefragt hast, wie kann ich hier Internetwerbung schalten
oder schalten lassen bei mir, hat Google gesagt, bei uns.
Und da sagt die EU-Kommission, wenn ihr das macht, dann führt das ja zu höheren
Kosten, weil ihr dann marktdominierende Stellung nutzt und ausbaut.
Und diese Kosten wurden einem Verbraucher ja dann weitergereicht,
weil wenn alle höhere Werbungskosten haben, dann müsst ihr alles teurer verkaufen.
Und deswegen solltet ihr euch nicht mehr weiter selbst bevorzugen.
Und außerdem geht die EU-Kommission davon aus, dass die Trennung von einem Teil
des Werbegeschäfts der einzige Weg sei, die Interessenkonflikte bei Google auszuräumen.
Weil noch mal das Einzige, das Wichtigste, womit Google Geld verdient ist,
also die Dienstleistung von Google ist, Leute suchen etwas, Google sagt, wo sie es finden.
Und das Geschäftsmodell von Google ist, Leute suchen etwas und andere bezahlen
uns dafür, dass sie die Antwort sind.
Da kann man schon von so einem inhärenten Interessenkonflikt sprechen.
Also den kann ich zumindest so den Anfangsverdacht kann ich da auch erkennen.
Dass das jetzt ausgerechnet im Bereich der Werbung dann sich der manifestiert
und nicht überall sonst geschenkt.
Aber klar, dass Google jetzt nicht geneigt ist, wenn man nach einem,
wie kann ich denn online werben zu antworten, hier ist das Suchergebnis, sondern, naja,
klicke hier. Wo möchtest du denn werben?
Da kann man schon, ich könnte dieser Argumentation jetzt folgen mit dieser Strafe.
Donald Trump aber nicht.
Donald Trump konnte dem nicht folgen und hat dann gesagt, dass er sich neue
Zölle überlegen musste, wenn das so weitergeht.
Aber erstmal entsendet er ja jetzt als nächstes das Militär nach Chicago und
hat sein Verteidigungsministerium und Kriegsministerium benannt.
Das heißt, eventuell haben wir noch eine Woche, bis er da wieder seine Aufmerksamkeit hinlenkt.
Und dann gab es ein bisschen komplizierter herzuführen, dieses Urteil.
Also, es gibt ja quasi diese grundsätzlichen Rechtsgrundlagen der EU-Kommission,
wo sie quasi sagen,
dieses und jenes Land befindet sich zwar außerhalb der GDPR,
der General Data Protection Directive, DSGVO in Deutschland,
und quasi auch außerhalb unseres Einflussbereiches.
Also, was machen wir denn jetzt da? Und die Grundrechte-Charta oder Charta,
ich weiß immer nicht, wie man das ausspricht, wahrscheinlich Charta,
Grundrechte-Charta der EU und der Vertrag über die Arbeitsweise der Europäischen Union,
die garantieren das Recht jeder Person auf Schutz ihrer personenbezogenen Daten.
So, und jetzt kommt die Datenschutzgrundverordnung und so weiter.
Was ja immer das große Thema ist, und wer behandelt das Thema besonders,
natürlich Max Schrems, der das Safe Harbor Abkommen damals ja zu Fall gebracht
hat, weil er darauf hingewiesen hat,
dass hier die Annahmen nicht gegeben sind.
Also die EU ist im Prinzip einfach aus wirtschaftlichem Interesse,
wahrscheinlich eher von US-Unternehmen als von europäischen Unternehmen,
aber auch in deren Interesse,
vor allem Interesse derer wirtschaftlicher Abhängigkeit von US-Unternehmen hingegangen
und hat gesagt, scheiße, wir haben hier quasi ein rechtliches Problem,
weil die sich gar nicht an unsere Datenschutzverordnung halten.
Und jetzt, wenn wir das nicht regeln, dann müsste quasi jedes dieser Unternehmen
das in irgendeiner Weise selber machen.
Und deswegen sind die hingegangen und haben quasi einen Angemessenheitsbeschluss
erlassen, den letzten am 10. Juni 2023.
Wo sie im Prinzip sagen, das ist schon okay.
Also in diesem Drittland, USA, herrscht ein angemessenes Schutzniveau und damit
geben wir eine Grundlage,
dass es keine zusätzliche Genehmigung geben muss.
Also sie haben im Prinzip einen Freifahrtschein für die USA gegeben.
Das ist ein anderes Rechtssystem, aber die groben Rechte gelten hier auch.
Passt schon.
Und mach mal. Und Max Schrems hat das ja, also es ist ja sehr naheliegend,
das zu kritisieren, zu Fall zu bringen und auch jetzt nicht so schwer glaube
ich gewesen, zu zeigen, dass das einfach nicht stimmt.
Und jetzt hat gegen diesen Angemessenheitsbeschluss vom 10.
Juli 2013 ein französischer Bürger, würde ich jetzt vermuten,
anhand des Nachnamens, geklagt und hat gesagt, der ist nichtig.
Und begründet hat er das mit zwei Kernfeststellungen.
Das erste, es gibt einen Data Protection Review Court, also ein Datenschutzgericht
der Vereinigten Staaten von Amerika.
Wo du quasi dann deine Datenschutzrechte überhaupt einklagen könntest.
Und dann hat er gesagt, naja, schönes Gericht haben sie da, aber das wird ja
von der Exekutive eingesetzt.
Und damit ist es ja nicht unabhängig, also folgt also nicht der Gewaltenteilung,
sondern die Exekutive sagt, hier haben wir ein Gericht für euch.
Und wer sich ein bisschen mit dieser ganzen Gewaltenteilungs- und Demokratietheorie
auseinandergesetzt hat, weiß, dass wir versuchen, in den Demokratien Exekutive,
Legislative und Judikative zu trennen.
Das ist das, was die USA gerade unter Trump alles wieder quasi in eins machen.
Also auch in eine Person, Donald Trump nämlich.
Und deswegen wird das ja auch als demokratiefeindlich von vielen eingeschätzt, was Donald Trump macht.
Und genau da sagt der Latombe hier, pass auf, dieses Data Protection Review
Court, das ist von der Exekutive und damit entspricht es nicht.
Ist das, was die EU-Kommission hier entschieden hat, einfach nicht akzeptabel.
Außerdem, sagt er, ist es ja Praxis der Nachrichtendienste der Vereinigten Staaten,
ohne vorherige Genehmigung durch
Richter oder eine Richterin oder eine unabhängige Verwaltungsbehörde,
Massensammeleerhebungen personenbezogener Daten durchzuführen.
Also quasi Daten, die aus der Europäischen Union im Transit sind.
Und da hängen die US-amerikanischen Geheimdienste drin, machen, Massenüberwachung.
Und diese Massenüberwachung ist weder von einer Richterin noch von einer unabhängigen
Aufsichtsbehörde genehmigt.
Und auch das ist ja nun mal nicht akzeptabel.
Und auf diesen beiden Punkten, erstens das Gericht, was über Beschwerden urteilt, ist von der Exekutive.
Und B, Massenüberwachung findet statt ohne richterliche oder unabhängige Aufsicht.
Hat er gesagt, dieser Beschluss kann ja dann nur nichtig sein.
Ich hoffe, das habe ich jetzt klar genug dargestellt. Also die beiden Punkte.
Es ist kein unabhängiges Gericht und Massenüberwachung finden ohne richterliche
oder unabhängige Aufsicht statt.
Und dann sagt das Gericht, in diesem Fall der Gerichtshof in der Europäischen
Union in seiner Mitteilung vom 3. September.
Ja, nee, das stimmt nicht. Wir weisen die komplette Klage ab.
Und sie sagen, dieser Data Protection Review Court,
da werden zwar die Richter von der Exekutive benannt, aber es gibt mehrere Garantien
und Bedingungen, mit denen der
verbunden ist, um die Unabhängigkeit dieser Mitglieder zu gewährleisten.
Die Richterinnen, die im DPRC sind, können nur vom Generalstaatsanwalt aus triftigen
Gründen abberufen werden und der Generalstaatsanwalt und Geheimdienste dürfen
die Arbeit dieser Richterinnen und Richter nicht behindern oder unrechtmäßig
beeinflussen. Deswegen ist das okay.
Und die EU-Kommission überwacht ja auch diesen Rechtsrahmen und würde sich da
was ändern, dann würden die sich da schon drum kümmern.
Also sagen sie, dieser DPRC ist unabhängig genug oder sagen wir nicht so abhängig,
dass es sich als für eine Klagebegründung gegen diesen Beschluss der EU-Kommission eignet.
Und zweitens sagen sie ja hier diese Sammelerhebung personenbezogener Daten,
da weiß das Gericht, daraufhin ich zitiere jetzt ein bisschen aus der Pressemitteilung,
dass nichts im Urteil Schrems II darauf hindeutet, dass diese zwingend einer
vorherigen Genehmigung durch eine unabhängige Behörde bedarf.
Also sie sagen, naja, wir haben ja schon geurteilt in dem zweiten Verfahren
mit Max Schrems, dass es jetzt zwingend notwendig ist, dass eine Massenüberwachung
unbedingt durch eine unabhängige Behörde oder eine Richterin kontrolliert wird.
Das ist ja gar nicht unbedingt so erzwungen.
Vielmehr sagen sie, dass die Entscheidung, mit der eine solche Sammelerhämmer
genehmigt wird, zumindest einer nachträglichen gerichtlichen Überprüfung unterzogen werden muss.
Also sie sagen, das ist schon okay, sowas ohne Richtervorbehalt zu machen.
Man muss nur nachher, Also reicht, wenn der Richter nachher guckt.
Und in diesem Fall ginge jetzt eben aus den Akten hervor, dass die von US-Nachrichtendiensten
betriebene Signalaufklärung, also die Massenüberwachung fremder Kommunikation,
nach dem Recht der Vereinigten Staaten einer nachträglichen gerichtlichen Prüfung
durch den DPRC eben dieses nicht unabhängige Gericht unterliegt.
Und deswegen wäre jetzt also nicht ersichtlich, dass die Sammelerhebungen personenbezogener
Daten, also die Massenüberwachung durch die US-Geheimdienste,
nicht den Anforderungen genüge, die sich insoweit aus dem Urteil Schrimps 2
ergeben und dass das Recht der Vereinigten Staaten keinen Rechtsschutz gewährleistet,
der dem durch das Unionsrecht garantierten der Sache nach gleichwertig ist.
Und deswegen sagen sie, alles klar, wir weisen die Klage insgesamt ab.
Das ist schon echt...
Habe ich das jetzt richtig verstanden? also sie sagen im Wesentlichen,
ja okay, die machen zwar Massenüberwachung, aber theoretisch könnte ja ein unabhängiges
Gericht, was eigentlich gar nicht so unabhängig ist, aber irgendwie ein bisschen schon,
könnte ja nachträglich dann irgendwann mal sagen, dass das ja so nicht geht.
Und dann können wir einfach reagieren.
Und deswegen war genau der andere Punkt, dieses Gericht ist nicht unabhängig,
war ja die andere Begründung der Klage und da sagen sie, ja nee,
das weisen wir zurück, weil die können ja nur aus triftigen Gründen abberufen werden.
Also ich weiß nicht, ob ich diesem Urteil so in dieser sehr kurzen Begründung
in der Pressemitteilung so folgen kann.
Es gibt natürlich noch einen längeren Volltext und eine Zusammenfassung,
die ich bisher nicht gelesen habe,
wo ich auch sagen muss, dass ich wahrscheinlich nicht ausreichend juristisch qualifiziert bin,
hier Fehler drin zu erkennen oder quasi eine Fehlerhaftigkeit dieses Urteils nachher nachzuweisen.
Das wird dann wahrscheinlich Neub machen.
Auch deren Einschätzung dazu haben wir verlinkt und sind natürlich gespannt,
wie Neub sich dazu verhalten wird.
Max Schrems sagt, es ist offensichtlich, dass dieses Gericht massiv,
abweicht von dem Case Law in Europa und wir sind relativ überrascht von diesem Ergebnis,
und wir werden das jetzt analysieren in den nächsten Tagen und schauen,
wie wir uns dazu verhalten.
Naja, soweit der Gerichtshof der Europäischen Union.
Also vor allem vor den dann doch sehr, sehr bedenklichen Entwicklungen in den USA,
was den sehr offensichtlichen und sehr schnell und radikal vorangetriebenen
Abbau der Checks and Balances und demokratischen Institutionen angeht,
ist das dann schon...
Ja, durchaus besorgniserregend oder überraschend ein derartiges Urteil 2025 zu hören.
Ja, wir sind mal gespannt, wie da weiter geschrämst wird.
Darauf können wir uns, glaube ich, verlassen, dass an der Sache weiter geschrämst wird.
Ja, eine andere interessante Entscheidung gab es in den USA,
da gab es nämlich gegen, jetzt kommen wir zu AI,
da gab es eine Klage, einen sogenannten Class-Action-Suit, wo sich ganz viele
zusammentun und sagen, wir klagen jetzt mal hier gemeinsam, damit das mehr Impact
hat, das ist ja sehr populär in den USA.
Gab es einen gegen Anthropik von Buchautoren.
Und ja, da ging es natürlich um das Training auf Büchern, was Anthropik nachweislich
gemacht hat und was Anthropik auch irgendwie auf Raubkopien gemacht hat.
Und da gab es jetzt interessanterweise eine Einigung.
Ich bin mir jetzt nicht ganz so sicher, wer jetzt da genauso profitieren wird,
das geht aus dem Bericht jetzt für mich zumindest nicht so hervor, aber unterm Strich,
ist von irgendwie 500.000 Büchern die Rede und dass irgendwie Ernst Roppec jetzt
bereit ist, 1,5 Milliarden US-Dollar zu zahlen an die Autoren dafür,
dass sie quasi da mehr oder weniger rückwirkend die,
Erlaubnis bekommen, da drin zu lesen und damit dann auch ihre Modelle zu trainieren.
Und wenn es irgendwie darüber hinaus geht, dann würden sie noch irgendwie 3000
Dollar pro Buch weiterhin oben drauflegen.
Das ist unfassbar, wie viel Geld in diesem AI-Apparat derzeit drin zu stecken scheint.
Und das ist natürlich sehr interessant, weil das ja im Prinzip ein offensichtlicher
Erfolg der Copyright-Fraktion ist.
Ja, also sagen wir mal, was heißt Fraktion, ich will das jetzt gar nicht so darstellen,
dass es da jetzt nur so zwei Positionen gibt, aber es stellt sich ja generell
in Zeiten dieses invasiven Trainings von AI-Modellen die Frage, inwiefern...
Ist das eigentlich eine urheberrechtliche Nutzung?
Also ist trainieren, lesen quasi, ist das schon eine Tat,
die in gewisser Hinsicht, weil bisher war ja immer Urheberrecht so auf Veröffentlichung
gemünzt und zwar auf die 1 zu 1 Veröffentlichung. Was hatten wir hier nicht alles?
Leistungsschutzrecht. Wenn da nur drei Worte aus irgendeiner Überschrift kopiert
werden, dann ist schon irgendwie alles ganz böse.
Und immer war es so dieser Wortlaut und das eins zu eins und genau so.
Und jetzt haben wir es halt sehr mit so einer weiteren Stufe von Derivative
Works zu tun in gewisser Hinsicht.
Und diese ganze Debatte ist ja auch eine hochphilosophische oder technikphilosophische Debatte.
Ist Training von Modellen eine urheberrechtlich relevante Tätigkeit?
Werden damit Urheberrechte verletzt? Und ich glaube, da kann man sehr unterschiedlicher
Meinung sein und ich würde für mich zum Beispiel gar nicht mal behaupten,
dass ich da auch nur eine hätte.
Also es ist wirklich ein sehr schwieriger Bereich.
So oder so gibt es jetzt hier diesen Fall und das könnte natürlich Auswirkungen
haben, wenn jetzt auch noch weitere Copyright-Holder, Movie-Industrie und so
weiter, sich jetzt genauso aufschwingen.
Also der, kurz weil man das für den Kontext nochmal hervorheben muss,
also die haben ihr Modell auf Büchern trainiert.
Und dann gab es schon im Sommer ein Urteil, wo ein Richter sagte,
ja pass auf, die Bücher, die sie gekauft haben,
Darauf durften sie auch trainieren. Also wo sie quasi sagen,
das hier, du hast das Buch bezahlt, du hast dein Modell lesen lassen,
das Modell gibt jetzt halt dieses Wissen auch wieder, aber du hast ja auch dafür bezahlt.
Und dann haben sie aber auch auf Pirated Books, also Bücher,
die sie noch nicht mal bezahlt haben, trainiert.
Und gesagt, das müssen wir separat machen. Und das ist jetzt dieser Teil,
wo es quasi nur um die, also nochmal separat um Bücher geht,
die sie nicht bezahlt haben.
Was ich halt auch irgendwie.
Auch schwierig finde, weil die eigentliche Frage,
ist das nicht jetzt vielleicht eine Vervielfältigung? Und das Recht haben sie
eigentlich nicht erworben.
Also das erste Urteil sagt, naja, du hast das Recht erworben,
dieses Buch zu lesen, dein Modell hat das gelesen, alles gut.
Jetzt ist dein Modell, das ist ja das Problem der klagenden Autoren,
die sagen, du hast hier ein Multimilliarden-Business gebaut mit gestohlenen Büchern.
Und das geht nicht. Und da sagen die Richter jetzt, die Bücher kannst du nicht
auch noch klauen. Dann musst du schon das Buch bezahlen.
Aber ich weiß auch ehrlich gesagt, wie würdest du das denn sehen?
Also offensichtlich ist es ja rechtlich in Ordnung. Aber wollen wir, dass du ein Buch kaufst?
Für, weiß ich nicht, was kostet so ein Buch, weiß ich 20, 50,
100 Dollar, je nachdem wie spezifisch das ist und dass der,
also es ist ja erkennbar, dass Anthropic nur durch das Lesen dieses Buches ein
direktes einen direkten Angriff auf die Notwendigkeit dass ein solches Buch
überhaupt existiert, vornimmt, oder?
Also deren Ziel ist ja dass Leute keine Bücher mehr kaufen, sondern mit Anthropic reden.
Das ist die Angst. Und das ist natürlich auch der Wunsch,
dass in eine Branche, in die gerade so viel Geld reinfließt,
so unfassbar viel Geld reinfließt, dass da alle auch irgendwie die Hand aufhalten wollen.
Das ist ja nachvollziehbar, wenn irgendwo gerade mal viel Geld unterwegs ist.
Aber das ist für mich irgendwie nicht relevant bei der Beurteilung mit,
was ist denn das jetzt eigentlich. ich.
Ich denke, es könnte auch eine andere Motivation geben, die in die andere Richtung zeigt.
Ich meine, Google hat auch sich alles durchgelesen.
Haben auch regelmäßig der Fall.
Ich weiß nicht genau, wie das rechtlich mit Google Books eigentlich so läuft,
weil ich meine, die veröffentlichen ja nun wirklich auch,
Bücher.
Ich vermute, dass wir da viel bezahlen.
Ja, das kann sein, weiß ich nicht. keine Ahnung von.
Aber,
genauso könntest du das ja auf jede einzelne Webseite auch erweitern.
Weil Urheberrecht gilt ja auch für die Texte, die du auf deiner Webseite hast.
Also wenn jetzt das ganze Internet gecrawlt wird, müsstest du sozusagen das
ganze Internet kaufen, damit du es überhaupt lesen darfst.
Naja, aber genau das, also,
genau diese Debatten wurden ja in Deutschland geführt, du erinnerst dich,
Leistungsschutzrecht.
Ja, hatte ich auch schon erwähnt und da halte ich halt auch für Quatsch und
ich meine, also Logbuch-Netzpolitik ist ja auch unser urheberrechtlicher Content.
Den haben wir hier geurhebert und da haben wir dann automatisch auch das Recht
da drauf und wenn jetzt Ansropik sich diese Webseite durchliest und die Transkripte
unseres Podcasts durchliest, dann ist das ja erstmal nicht sehr viel was anderes als ein Buch.
Urheberrechtlich geschützt, weil es automatisch urheberrechtlich geschützt ist.
Gleichzeitig haben wir aber mit der Erstellung von Logbuch Netzpolitik nutzen
wir ja eine große Reihe an journalistischen Medien, die wir dafür konsumieren,
die wir auch größtenteils alle bezahlen.
Und zwar nicht nur einmal, sondern dauerhaft.
Also wir nutzen sie als Quelle, wir geben sie als Quelle an,
wir verlinken sie dafür und wir leisten im Zweifelsfall einen Beitrag zu deren Fortbestand.
Also erstens, weil wir die bezahlen, zweitens, weil wir sie nutzen und referenzieren.
Und das war ja auch das Kernargument in den Leistungsschutzrecht-Debatten,
dass man gesagt hat, ey Leute, seid doch froh, dass Google irgendwie eure Inhalte
nimmt und in Google News aggregiert und Textausschnitte bietet.
Und dann euch auch noch diese Leserinnen frei Haus liefert.
Auch übrigens ein Argument, was die Presseverlage selber angebracht haben,
dass sie gesagt haben, der ganze Traffic kommt über Google.
Ja, okay, dann verklagt doch nicht eure Traffic-Quelle.
Bei Anthropic würde ich halt jetzt sagen ich bin mir nicht so sicher,
ob Anthropic sagt ich teaser dir mal die Lösung deines Problems an und wenn
du möchtest, kannst du dir dieses Buch kaufen, kriegst du auch noch einen Rabattcode von uns,
also da sehe ich schon einen.
Einen Unterschied und wenn Anthropic hingehen würde und sagen würde, pass auf,
dieses ganze Logbuch-Netzpolitik, das nervt ja auch so ein bisschen so lange
und dann lachen die immer und immer mit den Elchen und so das machen wir alles
weg, wir sagen dir einfach kurz, wir haben das mal für dich gehört und machen
dir eine Zusammenfassung davon und irgendwann kommt halt gar kein Link mehr
zu Logbuch Netzpolitik.
Dann kommt ja schon dieser, also da kommst du irgendwann so in Fragen des Urheberrechts,
die ja letztlich dem Ziel dienen sollen,
das Schaffen dieser Werke in irgendeiner Weise rechtlich in einen Rahmen zu
geben, der ihre Erstellung finanziell nachhaltig macht.
Ja, so, aber was man jetzt meint, was die Motivation ist, sowohl auf der gelesenen
als auch auf der lesenden Seite, ist ja erstmal unabhängig von dem eigentlichen Recht.
Wenn du sagst so, ja, aber Google linkt ja wieder zurück auf mich,
da habe ich ja was davon, dann interpretiere ich das Recht jetzt mal so und
wenn sie das nicht machen, dann interpretiere ich das halt so.
Und so funktioniert aber Recht an der Stelle irgendwie nicht so richtig.
Also ich habe da, wie gesagt, auch gar keine klare Position.
Urheberrecht ist auch schwierig genug wie Recht generell.
Möchte ich gerne, dass die Webseite von den Modellen gelesen wird.
Ich sehe jetzt keinen großen Nachteil da drin, dass sie es tut,
abgesehen davon, dass die Suchmaschinen alle Webserver platt machen.
Ob wir da irgendwann mal zitiert werden oder nicht oder in irgendeiner Form
Wissen beitragen, ja vielleicht.
Ich meine, die lesen auch unsere Transkripte und auch unsere Sicht der Dinge
fließt letzten Endes in diese Komprimierung des Netzes mit rein.
Da möchte ich eigentlich schon eher dabei sein.
Ich möchte jetzt nicht, dass sie jetzt nicht nur die Nazi-Seiten durchlesen
und daraus ihr Weltbild ableiten.
Also das ist natürlich auch so eine Motivation.
Die Frage ist halt nur, wenn jetzt die Bücher 3000 Dollar pro Buch bekommen.
Kriegen wir dann auch 3.000 Dollar pro Podcast-Ausgabe. Was haben wir jetzt? LNP 531.
Lass mal kurz nachrechnen.
Also so verstehe ich das. Ich habe uns dann schon hier eingetragen unter Anthropic,
Copyright Settlement.com.
1,5 Millionen würden wir dann kriegen.
Ja, mindestens. Und 3.000 für diese Sendung. Ich würde sagen,
wir erhöhen jetzt auch auf zweiwöchentlichen Rhythmus.
Habe ich schon mitgerechnet. Und das ist ja nur das, was wir von ein Scropic bekommt.
Das kriegen wir dann auch von OpenAI, von Perplexity, von all diesen Maschinen
und die Open Source Modelle müssen natürlich auch bezahlen.
Ja klar. Wo sind wir denn?
Also mal her mit der Kohle. Da wird es dann nämlich auch wieder schwierig.
Gilt dann das Urheberrecht sozusagen nur, wenn du selber damit Geld verdienst?
Darf es jetzt überhaupt ein offenes Modell geben? Dürfen wir ein für alle freies,
offenes, mit Trainingsdaten angebotenes Modell geben?
Oder müssen die dann auch für alle Bücher bezahlen?
Ist das Weltwissen ohnehin nur noch durch Bezahlen verfügbar?
Oder kann man das auch irgendwie anders zusammentragen?
Also da kommt für mich eine ganze Menge zusammen, wo ich keine gute Antwort drauf habe.
Also genau das wollten wir ja auch, glaube ich, mit dieser Section ein bisschen
herauskitzeln, zumal es die eine Seite ist, wie jetzt irgendwie,
wie wird mit vergangenen Werken umgegangen, die andere Seite ist,
wie gestaltet sich das denn in der Zukunft?
Also was ist denn, wo kommt denn dann jetzt noch neues Wissen her?
Wer soll denn jetzt noch, also wer hat noch einen.
Anreiz,
überhaupt neues Wissen zu generieren.
Also, irgendjemand muss ja die Trainingsdaten für diese Modelle schreiben.
Ich muss ja irgendwo herkommen.
Oder ist die Idee, könnte ja sein, dass man sagt, weißt du was,
lass uns einfach von der AI selber machen.
Es gibt ja diese Idee, die dann sagen, ja, die AI, die erforscht jetzt hier
alles und die löst jetzt bei Fragen des Universums usw.
Wir müssen einfach nur warten und irgendwie Öl nachkippen.
Aber dass jetzt quasi auch so diese, dass sie in irgendeiner Weise auch für
ihre Modelle irgendeine klare Lösung haben müssen,
wo das in Zukunft das Material herkommt, wir haben ja auch schon öfter darüber
gesprochen, dass sie jetzt schon quasi Schwierigkeiten haben,
überhaupt noch Lernmaterial zu finden.
Und deswegen irgendwie Geld für irgendwelche Reddits und die Orte im Internet
bieten wollen, wo Menschen noch Inhalte reinschreiben.
Ja, und dann schreiben die Leute gar nichts mehr und dann wird nur noch der
ganze Slop gegessen und dann sind wir schon wieder beim Internet-BSE.
Ja, aber dann sind wir endlich in Idiocracy. Ich habe es ja immer gesagt, das wird noch lustig.
Gut, lassen wir das offen und für eure Kommentare vor allem frei.
Dann hat vielleicht, also jetzt auch nicht überraschend, nur mal kurz behandelt,
hat die New York Times ein bisschen analysiert, wie sich die Antworten von Grog,
dem AI-Chatbot von X, also Elon Musk,
verändert haben.
Und, also das ist jetzt einige Wochen her, also das Ding dreht ja regelmäßig irgendwie durch,
weil da hat es sich ja irgendwie als Mekka-Hitler bezeichnet und irgendwelche
komischen Sachen, also das Ding ist da irgendwie, da sieht man mal,
ist ja bei Tesla eh immer so, alle anderen kümmern sich um ihre Safeguards, sagen, ah,
hier, selbstfahrendes Auto machen wir ein Leider dran, und Musk sagt immer so,
nee, nee, das braucht man nicht. Wir fahren einfach mit der Kamera gegen den Baum.
Und bei AI ist es ja ähnlich, dass er dann sagt, die brauchen wir gar nicht
zu korrigieren oder so, da brauchen wir auch gar keine Safeguards.
Er hat ja dann auch irgendwie, das sind vor ein paar Wochen,
das hatten wir, ich weiß gar nicht, ob wir das so behandelt haben, waren so die Prompts.
Das Ding hat ja unterschiedliche Charaktere, die da quasi zur Wahl stehen.
Und quasi die Primer, wo dieser Charakter beschrieben ist, Da steht dann irgendwie
für den Comedian, du musst irgendwie Vollgas geben und alle Grenzen überschreiten,
inklusive dir irgendwelche Dinge in den Arsch stecken.
Das ist komisch. Der verfolgt auf jeden Fall auch hier einen Weg jenseits der
Pfade, die alle anderen gehen.
Dann war er mit seinem Grog nicht zufrieden.
Und dann wurde Grock halt, also wirtschaftliche und staatsbürgerliche Themen
wurde ja immer konservativer.
Und in den sozialen Themen wurde dann irgendwie Linker. Dann hat er gesagt,
nee, das wollen wir nicht. Und jetzt auf einmal ändert sich das halt wieder.
Der Musk war dann unzufrieden. Und jetzt verhält sich das Ding halt politisch anders.
Weil es zum Beispiel wurde, es hat es dann zu diesem Woke-Mind-Virus,
was den Musk ja irgendwie groß beschäftigt, dass das irgendwie ein Gedankenvirus
wäre, sich mit Rechten von Minderheiten und so auseinanderzusetzen.
Das ist ein Gedankenvirus.
Sagt halt Grog aus dem Standardmaterial, das ist in der Regel eine Übertreibung.
Hat Herr Maas gesagt, nee, das kann ja wohl gar nicht sein. Der sagt so jetzt
bitte was anderes. Und jetzt gehen die quasi hin und machen über diese.
Prompt Primer wird das Ding halt korrigiert.
Wird gesagt, pass auf, folgendes ist eine Wahrheit, folgendes ist eine Wahrheit,
folgendes ist eine Wahrheit.
Und unter diesen, unter Annahme dieser Grundwahrheiten, geh jetzt bitte durch
dein Lernmaterial und gib eine Antwort, die diese Grundwahrheiten nicht mehr in Frage stellt.
Der macht quasi politische Korrekturen auf seiner AI da.
Meine Fresse. Also das ist...
Schlimm ist das alles. Zeigt aber auch wirklich die Gefahr, wenn halt diese
Systeme quasi so wie eine Suchmaschine oder wie so eine Wahrheitsmaschine benutzt werden.
Und machen wir uns nichts vor, viele Leute sehen das auch so und das ist halt
dann ein perfektes Produkt für so eine latente Beeinflussung einer Meinung,
einer gesamtgesellschaftlichen Meinung oder Meinungsbildung.
Das Ding, also etwas radikaler kann man das natürlich sehen.
Also man könnte hier auf den Schluss ziehen und der ist sicherlich auch nicht so falsch.
Das Ding soll ja, also Lernen ist ja primär faktenbasiert.
Also was wir ja, was man ja möchte, ist das Ding, dass das Fakten kennt und
aus Fakten korrekte Schlüsse zieht.
Und sehr zum Ärger von Elon Musk ist halt ein Modell, was Zusammenhänge zwischen Fakten ergründet,
am Ende politisch eher links und
muss quasi mit der Brechtstange danach irgendwie nur korrigiert werden,
um diese ganzen etwas radikal rechten Positionen, für die das Modell eben leider
keine Faktenbasis gefunden hat, in seinem Lehrmaterial.
Die Realität ist irgendwie immer links. Ist das auch schon mal aufgefallen?
Die hat so einen linken Bias, die Realität.
Ja, das ist das Woke Mind Virus. Na klar, Tim, was denkst du denn?
Das Woke Mind Virus hat die Realität irgendwie befallen.
Kann dir mal einer in den Knast stecken, die Realität?
Dann kamen wir eine,
unser Dauerbrenner. Aber das sind so Themen, ja. Wir machen den Podcast jetzt bald wie viele Jahre?
14 Jahre, ne? 14 Jahre bald.
Und ich weiß ja auch, wir brauchen so ein paar Themen, die müssen einfach auch
immer weiter diskutiert werden, damit wir hier eine Geschäftsgrundlage haben.
Das ist das Abo, ja.
Aber so einige Themen, das wäre schon wirklich okay, wenn die jetzt einfach
mal... Ich habe ja auch gar keinen Bock mehr, die würde ich gerne outsourcen.
Das können wir demnächst von der KI erledigen lassen.
Aber die...
Europa möchte mal wieder die Vorratsdatenspeicherung einführen.
Und deswegen sagt die Europäische Kommission, sagt, ja, pass auf,
Leute, Vorratsdatenspeicherung haben wir uns überlegt, wäre ja mal wieder eine gute Idee. Und.
Weil wir das, bevor wir jetzt unseren nächsten Anlauf machen,
machen wir jetzt mal eine Konsultation.
Und das Ziel unserer Konsultation ist, dass wir von den wichtigsten Kategorien
von Interessenträgern in diesem Bereich, das ist Öffentlichkeit,
Personen im Bereich der öffentlichen Sicherheit, Justiz, Inneres und Digitalpolitik,
Polizei und Justizbehörden, Sachverständige für Cybersicherheit,
Behörden, die für den Datenschutz und den Schutz der Privatsphäre zuständig
sind, Berufsverbände von Anwältinnen und Anwälten, Hochschulen,
Forschung und Denkfabriken, Organisationen der Zivilgesellschaft,
das sind so die wichtigsten Interessenträger hier.
Und Leute, Organisationen, die sich für Rechte von Opfern oder allgemeiner Grundrechte
einsetzen und Industrie. Also das sind jetzt hier die Interessenträger.
Die sollen jetzt alle mal was dazu sagen zu unserer Vorratsspeicherung hier.
Haben wir einen Fragebogen gemacht. Und da könnt ihr jetzt dran teilnehmen.
Da wollen wir jetzt erstmal sicherstellen, dass eben alle Stakeholder gehört werden.
Und ja, da haben wir einen Online-Fragebogen.
Also es ist schon auch lustig, weil also diese gesamte, diese Idee der Vorratsdatenspeicherung,
die ist ja nun wirklich, die muss ja inzwischen abschließend erörtert sein.
Also es wurde ja einfach vor so vielen Gerichten geklagt und argumentiert und
in jeder Anhörung über Verfahren zu dem Thema,
gab es dann Sachverständige, die irgendwas geschrieben haben.
Ich weiß nicht, ob es jetzt zu viel dazu gibt, dass man damit jetzt noch ein
neuronales Modell trainieren könnte, was der Kommission einfach sagt, geht nicht.
Deswegen müssen sie sich nochmal, weil es einfach noch nicht genug Datenbasis
gibt, müssen sie jetzt eine Konsultation machen.
Es gibt drei Hauptabschnitte. Die erste ist allgemeine Fragen zur Notwendigkeit.
Also brauchen wir das überhaupt? Der zweite ist Grundrechte und der dritte ist
irgendwie sowas wie Baseline dazu.
Und naja, es wird auf jeden Fall von Edri und in der Übersetzung von Digitale
Gesellschaft durchaus dazu geraten.
Also was ich gerade als Basis, Scope, also im Prinzip, was ist die Übersetzung von Scope?
Ich kenne es nur quasi als Untersuchungsbereich, Reichweiten,
Geltungsbereich, glaube ich, wäre die richtige Übersetzung.
Und da sind insgesamt 18 Fragen, die man da beantworten kann.
Es gibt von Edri und von Digitale Gesellschaft eben auch Empfehlungen oder Erläuterungen,
wie man diese Frage zu verstehen hat und über Empfehlungen, ob man der Frage
zustimmen sollte oder der Aussage zustimmen sollte oder nicht.
Und wahrscheinlich ist es ganz sinnvoll, daran teilzunehmen.
Entsprechend haben wir das verlinkt, sowohl von Edri als auch von Digitale Gesellschaft
und auch den Link zu dieser Konsultation.
Es ist einerseits eben durchaus, denke ich, etwas bitter,
dass das überhaupt noch stattfindet, aber genauso darf man natürlich diesem
potenziell auch intendierten Ermüdungseffekt nicht anheimfallen und muss sich
eben hier auch erneut noch einmal mit einbringen an diesem wunderschönen demokratischen
Option der Konsultation,
bevor die Kommission sich erneut daran machen will,
irgendwie unsere Grundrechte anzugreifen in Richtung einer Massenüberwachung.
Ja, es bleibt nichts, es wird nichts ausgelassen.
So, dann mal was völlig anderes, auch wenn es so auch ein bisschen das Digitale
betrifft, nämlich Navigationssysteme.
Die sind ja sehr populär. Ich kann mich noch ganz gut daran erinnern,
als so Anfang der 90er Jahre dieses ganze GPS alles noch so neu war.
Also die Satelliten, die Autos mit Satellitennavigation.
Das war geil, da stand dann dran, das Auto hat ein Satellitennavigationssystem
und denkst so, boah, fuck, Alter, mein Auto mit Satelliten, das ist doch schon cool.
Ja, die Autos hatten das dann irgendwann auch, aber dass es das überhaupt erst
mal gab, weil das gab es ja eigentlich alles erst so ab den 90er Jahren,
so war das einfach so eine Vision und hat dann noch eine Weile gedauert,
bis wir dann eben mit Smartphones so eine,
universelle Verfügbarkeit haben, auch für alle möglichen Dienste.
Und ja, diese universelle Verfügbarkeit hat natürlich auch dazu geführt,
dass wir jetzt auch in so eine universelle Abhängigkeit davon geraten sind.
Insbesondere, was den Flugverkehr betrifft, aber nicht nur den Flugverkehr,
auch den Schiffsverkehr, die jetzt eigentlich auch weitgehend auf,
Navigationssysteme, umstellen.
Du bist ja, hast ja eh was gegen Leuchttürme, hast du ja hier schon gesagt.
Die sind dann ganz schön außer Dienst gestellt.
Und auch wenn es interessante Technologien gibt, die so eine Entwicklung sind.
Da war GPS quasi ein Leuchtturmprojekt.
Was ist das Wort? Genau.
Ähm,
Ja, was wollte ich jetzt sagen? Also es gibt interessante technologische Ansätze,
vielleicht auch so eine Navigation mal ohne Satelliten zu machen,
das ist aber nach alles so ein bisschen in den Kinderschuhen,
ist es einfach derzeit die Realität.
Jetzt gab es vor kurzem große Aufregung, weil ja angeblich Ursula von Allianz
Flugzeug, mit dem sie nach Bulgarien, nach Plovdiv geflogen ist,
eine GPS-Störung hatte und es wurde dann gleich wild spekuliert,
was denn dafür der Grund sein könnte.
Moment, also die Störung hatte es auf jeden Fall. Das ist ja billig,
weil du gerade angeblich gesagt hast.
Die Piloten haben ja, glaube ich, gefunkt.
Also das GPS des Flugzeugs war auf jeden Fall gestört. Ob GPS gestört war, ist die andere Frage.
Und es wurde dann schnell viel über GPS-Jamming und Spoofing berichtet.
Es steht so, wir können das mit Ursula von der Leyen mal so ein bisschen beiseite
legen, weil es gibt keine klaren Beweise dafür, dass es jetzt wirklich dieses
Jamming oder Spoofing dort gegeben hat.
Es lag natürlich ein bisschen nahe, weil man sich dachte so,
oh Bulgarien, Schwarzes Meer und so weiter.
Plovdiv allerdings ist relativ weit weg und wenn man auf so eine GPS-Jammer-Map
mal guckt, wir haben auch eine verlinkt, wo nachweislich tatsächlich Störungen
vorliegen von Navigationssystemen.
Dann ist das jetzt kein Hotspot, weil die Stadt relativ weit weg vom Schwarzen
Meer ist und da hat das einfach mit diesem unmittelbaren Kriegsgeschehen nichts zu tun.
Sehr wohl gibt es das aber.
Um Königsberg herum ist im Prinzip Dauerjamming angesagt und das hat den Flugverkehr
auch schon erheblich eingeschränkt.
Also nicht nur, dass die Fernstreckenflüge nicht mehr über Russland stattfinden
können, auch in diesem ganzen Peripherierbereich ist es schwierig.
Vielleicht müssen wir einmal noch kurz erklären, wie so ein Satelliten-Navigationssystem
ungefähr funktioniert und was Jamming oder Spoofing in dem Kontext bedeutet.
Genau, das sollten wir auf jeden Fall tun.
Willst du machen?
Ja, wir können das auch gerne zusammen machen. Also im Wesentlichen sind ja,
also erstmal, was gibt es überhaupt für Systeme?
Es gibt natürlich GPS und wenn man heute GPS sagt, meint man irgendwie auch
alle irgendwie. Die Europäer haben ihr eigenes System, Galileo und auch die
Russen haben ihr eigenes System, GLONASS.
Und ich warte eigentlich nur darauf, dass die Chinesen auch nochmal anfangen eins aufzuziehen.
Und alle arbeiten mehr oder weniger nach demselben Prinzip,
nämlich diese Satelliten haben alle extrem genaue Uhren und diese extrem genauen
Uhren werden ausgelesen und per Funk wird einfach die Zeit ausgesendet.
Das heißt, man empfängt eigentlich von jedem Satelliten die Zeit und jetzt kann
man, wenn man irgendwo diese Signale empfängt von mehreren dieser Satelliten,
an der Laufzeit quasi im Verhältnis zu der darin enthaltenen Uhrzeit feststellen
oder ausrechnen, wo man ist.
Weil der Satellit, jeder Satellit sendet dieses Funksignal.
Das Funksignal bewegt sich mit Lichtgeschwindigkeit und,
Dadurch, dass es sich nur mit Lichtgeschwindigkeit bewegt, kommt es zu unterschiedlichen
Zeitpunkten an, je nachdem, wie weit ein Satellit weg ist.
Ich stehe auf der Erde und empfange das Signal von fünf Satelliten.
Diese fünf Signale kommen zu unterschiedlichen Zeiten bei mir an.
Obwohl alle Satelliten sagen, es ist, was weiß ich, gerade genau 12 Uhr Mittag.
Und dann kriege ich diese fünf Nachrichten mit minimalen Laufzeitunterschieden,
woraus ich dann als Empfänger zurückrechne, alles klar, der eine,
der ist am weitesten weg und zwar so viel weiter als der andere,
weil das Signal ist ja so und so viel im Unterschied zu mir gekommen.
Und der dritte ist noch weiter weg.
Und so, was wir ja aus Mathematik kennen, sobald du drei Punkte hast und um
die einen Radius malen kannst, dann kannst du dich triangulieren und deine Position
bestimmt, nämlich die Abstände zu den drei Punkten.
Weil es nur noch zwei Punkte gibt, die, wo die Bedingung erfüllt wäre,
dass diese Abstände so sind und der eine liegt auf der Erde und der andere liegt
irgendwie sehr, sehr viele Kilometer genau gerade über dir.
Und weil du da wahrscheinlich nicht bist, beziehungsweise Also wenn du da bist,
weißt du es, sagst du alles klar, dann bin ich wahrscheinlich an diesem Punkt auf der Erdoberfläche.
Oder noch nicht mal. Also könnte auch in der Luft sein, funktioniert auch in der Luft. Korrekt?
Genau. Und heutzutage ist es so, dass die Telefone ja auch alle entsprechende Empfänger haben.
Das heißt, die können diese Signale direkt empfangen.
Sprich, jedes Smartphone ist auch ein, ich sage jetzt einfach mal GPS.
Mittlerweile unterstützen die Smartphones alle diese Dienste und können von
daher auch sich mit mehreren abgleichen.
Außerdem ist es so, dass es im Mobilfunk auch noch zusätzliche Informationen
gibt, die man direkt von den Mobilfunkzellen bekommt, weil die ja auch wissen, wo sie sind.
Und dann kann man eben darüber auch nochmal diese Berechnung sehr viel genauer durchführen.
Und was die auch noch nutzen, das fiel mir jetzt gerade so ein,
weil du auch sagtest, als wir dann die Telefone kamen.
Das erste iPhone auf jeden Fall, und vielleicht sogar auch noch das iPhone 3G,
weiß ich nicht genau, die hatten kein GPS.
Die haben ihre Positionierung tatsächlich vorgenommen und machen das auch heute
nach meiner Kenntnis wahrscheinlich immer noch, unterstützt von WLAN und Mobilfunk-Maps.
Das ist tatsächlich so, wenn du so einen GPS-Empfänger anmachst und sagst, sag mal bitte,
dann braucht der ja seine Zeit, um erstmal die ganzen Satellitensignale nacheinander
zu erfassen und dann irgendwann zu sagen, dann bin ich jetzt wahrscheinlich hier.
Also in den Ende der 90er Jahre so ein GPS-Gerät hast du angemacht,
hat erstmal 20 Minuten gedauert.
Nicht 20 Minuten, aber es hat einen erkennbaren Zeitraum gedauert,
bis das Ding dir sagen konnte, hier und da bin ich. Ähm.
Und um diesen, um das zu optimieren, und das seht ihr, glaube ich,
heute noch, wenn man so ein Handy rausholt,
auf Google Maps oder so, dass dann gerne auch mal erst ein Kreis gemacht wird
und dann sagt er, hier bist du wohl. Und dieser Kreis, der ist,
Zumindest war es früher so, größtenteils erst mal diese grobe Navigations- und
Ortsbestimmung anhand von den WLANs, die das Ding empfängt.
Und wahrscheinlich auch noch irgendwie von der Cell-ID.
Genau, es fließt alles mit rein und ist richtig, WiFi wird auch heute noch benutzt,
deswegen gibt es auch so Effekte, dass man auf einen Kongress kommt und dann
auf einmal wird man in Schweden oder so verortet,
weil dort auf einmal WLAN-Access-Points zum Einsatz kommen, die zwei Wochen
vorher noch in Schweden irgendwie die ganze Zeit rumstanden und die entsprechenden
Datenbanken, die das permanent alles einsammeln und abgleichen,
haben dann halt einfach so, ja was, den Access-Point kenne ich,
du bist wahrscheinlich in Schweden.
Und dann hast du irgendwie nicht so eine gute Verbindung durch die Mauern zu
deinem Mobilfunk-Tower, dann ist das WLAN erstmal das Erste, was ausgewertet wird.
Also es gibt zahlreiche Methoden, wie man eben herausfinden kann, wo man ist.
Und da sind halt die GNSS-Systeme, also die Global Navigation Satellite Systems,
sind dann im Prinzip die einzigen, die so outdoor wirklich zuverlässig funktionieren,
wenn kein WLAN und vielleicht auch kein Mobilfunk ist, also wenn es außer Daten-Ellchen
sozusagen nichts anderes gibt, dann müssen halt die Satelliten ranhören.
So, aber was ist jetzt mit diesem Jamming und was mit diesem Spoofing?
Jamming heißt einfach, jemand versucht, dass du deinen GPS fix,
wie das so schön heißt, finden kannst, indem einfach diese Frequenzbereiche,
auf denen man empfängt, durch andere Signale mit Noise zugemacht werden.
Nicht finden kannst. Nicht finden kannst. Du hast gerade das nicht vergessen.
Also du kannst den GPS fix nicht bekommen, weil...
Weil es einfach... Ja, du versuchst zu hören, aber jemand schreit so laut,
dass du einfach nichts hören kannst.
Das ist eigentlich das, was man gemeinhin unter GPS-Jamming versteht.
GPS-Spoofing ist eine andere Methode, die versucht...
Legitim aussehende Datenpakete auszusenden, die dann aber nicht von einem Satelliten
kommen, sondern von irgendwas anderem, was auf terrestrischer Basis ist.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob das wirklich ein paketbasiertes Funkprotokoll ist,
aber Funksignale wäre glaube ich die Antwort.
Ja, aber es sind digitale Informationen, also es sind sozusagen da drin,
also insofern gibt es schon ein Paket im Sinne von einer Zeiteinheit, die du halt empfängst,
du empfängst halt eine Uhrzeit und wenn also jetzt jemand anders sagt,
ich bin aber jetzt der Satellit und meine Uhrzeit ist sowieso und du würdest
das als eine legitime Information,
als legitimes Datenpaket empfangen, dann geht halt deine Berechnung kaputt.
Und das ist eben dieses Spoofing. Und jetzt wissen wir ja alle,
wenn man sich eben gegen falsche Daten schützen will, dann muss man das in irgendeiner Form verschlüsseln.
Und tatsächlich sieht zum Beispiel das GPS… Nein.
Nein, falsch, falsch, sorry, da muss ich sofort unterbrechen.
Wenn du dich gegen falsche Signale schützen möchtest, dann musst du die nicht verschlüsseln.
Sondern… Unterschreiben. Signieren.
Ja, also musst du Verschlüsselung benutzen. Das war das, was ich hätte sagen sollen.
Schön, dass wir da ganz korrekt sind.
Also benutzt Verschlüsselung, um sicherzustellen, dass die Nachricht authentisch ist.
Das heißt, sie ist digital signiert, sprich es gibt einen Schlüssel,
den du heranziehen kannst, um das überprüfen zu können.
Und jetzt ist es aber tatsächlich so, dass das öffentliche, freie,
privat nutzbare GPS so etwas nicht vorsieht.
Auch GLONASS, das russische Navigationssystem, sieht sowas nicht vor.
Wohl aber das europäische Galileo-System.
Da gibt es also im Rahmen des sogenannten Open Service Navigation Message Authentication
Bereichs gibt es eine Spezifikation, die das schöne Tesla-Protokoll benutzt, lustigerweise.
Also ausnahmsweise soll Tesla, jetzt macht er zu Beitrag, dass Dinge besser werden.
Steht für Timed Efficient Stream Loss Tolerant Authentication und bedeutet im
Prinzip, dass du diese Zeiteinheiten tatsächlich erledigst.
Signiert empfängst. Also die sind quasi durch Verschlüsselung,
ich bin jetzt ganz genau, durch Verschlüsselung entsprechend signiert,
sodass man überprüfen kann, dass die auch echt sind, wenn man denn diesen Schlüssel hat.
Wenn jetzt dieser Schlüssel aber allgemein bekannt wäre, dann könnte natürlich
auch jemand diesen Schlüssel nehmen und damit durch die Gegend bufen.
Deswegen macht man das so, dass erst die Signale ankommen und der Schlüssel,
mit dem man das überprüfen kann, der wird dann erst nachträglich gesendet.
Sodass man das zwar nicht sofort, sondern eben nur mit einer gewissen Zeitverzögerung
überprüfen kann, aber man kann es dann überprüfen.
Und diese Zeitverzögerung liegt irgendwo so zwischen 30 und 300 Sekunden.
Also zwischen einer halben und fünf Minuten.
Ja und das soll jetzt auch gepusht werden, also es existiert bereits,
diese Technik ist implementiert im Galileo-System,
sie ist nur in ganz vielen Clients nicht implementiert, also kein Smartphone
hat das, es gibt lediglich Empfänger im Industriebereich, die das machen und
wahrscheinlich auch im Militärbereich.
Man muss dazu sagen, das militärische GPS, was auf einer anderen Frequenz sind, hat das auch.
Also es ist nicht so, dass die Amerikaner jetzt erst auf die Idee gekommen werden,
mal so eine Technologie einzusetzen.
Es ist halt nur für das öffentlich nutzbare GPS nicht der Fall.
Und deswegen halt auch in allen Flugzeugen und in allen Schiffen nicht,
die jetzt kein Militär sind.
Ich habe früher sehr viel mit GPS experimentiert und längere Geschichte.
Irgendwo ist mir aufgefallen, dass das bei 200-300 kmh nicht mehr funktioniert.
Weißt du, wieso?
GPS?
Also es ging darum, ich wollte damals bestimmte Dinge um die Welt fliegen lassen
und aufzeichnen, wo sie sich befinden.
Und es ging damals um unsere GSM-Forschung, längere Geschichte.
Und dann habe ich festgestellt, dass meine Idee, oder ich dachte dann,
ja, wenn das dann so fliegt, dann wird dieses GPS ja irgendwann,
dann sehe ich ja, wenn es fliegt.
Und immer, wenn das Flugzeug gestartet ist, sind meine GPS, die ich hatte,
die haben immer quasi schon ungefähr beim, also meistens noch vor dem Start
des Flugzeugs, der, glaube ich, so bei 250 oder 300 kmh ist,
üblicherweise kurz davor haben die aufgehört, Positionen zu liefern, die ich hatte.
Und der Hintergrund davon ist, dass man vermeiden möchte, dass Leute wie ich
Interkontinentalraketen bauen, die mit dem GPS navigieren.
Insofern muss an den Flugzeugen schon irgendetwas anders sein an dem GPS.
Also wenn die bei so hohen, bei ihren höheren Geschwindigkeiten noch einen Fix
kriegen, ich vermute, dass das irgendwie halt eine Limitation dieser,
was weiß ich, Cheapo-Dinger war.
Aber man hat sich auf jeden Fall bei dem Bau dieses Systems sehr darüber Gedanken
gemacht, dass es einerseits der gesamten Welt dienen kann und soll und gleichzeitig aber natürlich,
für militärische Nutzung gedacht ist.
Und es ist nach meinem Verständnis tatsächlich so, dass die USA morgen entscheiden
können, dass GPS halt aus ist oder nicht mehr für Zivilisten,
für zivilistische Anwendungen sinnvoll nutzbar.
Während sie ihren militärischen Bereich davon vollständig getrennt haben, also offenbar.
Okay.
Ja, vielleicht noch ein Nachtrag, weil die Frage vielleicht schnell kommt.
Warum muss man überhaupt einen Schlüssel versenden? Warum benutzt man nicht Public-Private-Key?
Kennen wir ja sozusagen aus dem Internet. Da könnte man ja einfach...
Anstrengende Körper, zu teure...
Genau, also es wäre zu viel Daten und zu viel Rechenaufwand für die Geräte,
deswegen hat man sich eben hier für so ein einfaches symmetrisches Verschlüsselungsverfahren
darauf geeinigt und das Problem eben durch diese zeitversetzte Senden gelöst.
Ja.
Ich habe mir das jetzt gerade nebenbei noch mal so rausgeschaut. Also dieses,
das ist glaube ich kein Feature von GPS selber, dass meine Billo-Sensoren da
an einer bestimmten Geschwindigkeit nicht mehr funktioniert haben.
Aber die tatsächlichen GPS-Geräte, die sind so ab 1900 kmh oder fluoro.
Flughöhe von über 1800 Meter, dann schalten die auf jeden Fall ab.
Und das ist der Interkontinentalraketenschutz.
Also muss Interkontinentalraketengeschwindigkeitsbeschränkungen auf 1900 kmh
und unter 17 Kilometer Flughöhe.
Zu der von der Leyen Sache noch kurz. für größere Irritationen in dem Kontext
hat jetzt gesorgt, dass A...
Die Piloten eben sagten, unser GPS hier funktioniert nicht, gleichzeitig aber
an jedem Flugzeug dieses ADSB-System ist.
Womit Flugzeuge auf einem relativ
reichweiten Low-Frequency-Protokoll ihre Positionsdaten durchgeben.
Und diese Daten hat das Flugzeug problemlos und korrekt weitergesendet.
Also wenn du dir das Flugzeug auf Flightradar anschaust, dann siehst du exakt
100% eine saubere Positionsdaten über den Zeitraum.
Das heißt, das GPS von dem ADS-B-System hat funktioniert und es ist davon auszugehen,
dass dieses Instrumentensystem, was die Piloten haben,
eben einen weiteren GPS hat, der dann eben offenbar nicht funktioniert. hat.
Insofern noch auch irgendwie großes Hin und Her darüber, ob da jetzt ein technischer
Fehler vorlag oder ein Jamming oder was auch immer, ob das jetzt ein Angriff
auf das Leben von Ursula von der Leyen war,
da wird jetzt halt viel darüber diskutiert von Leuten, die sich berufen fühlen, das jetzt aufzuklären.
Mit anderen Worten, nicht von uns.
Nicht von uns. Wir versuchen weiterhin, Interkontinentalraketen im Rahmen der
internationalen Geschwindigkeitsbeschränkungen für Interkontinentalraketen zu bauen.
Und zu verschicken.
Genau.
Und zwar an alle, die hier kritisieren, wie wir hier unsere Sendung machen.
Nee, Quatsch. Macht mal ruhig weiter. So, da haben wir es, oder?
Ja.
Alles klar. Super. Leute, dann wünschen wir euch viel Spaß mit diesen Informationen.
Macht was draus und wir freuen uns auf eure Kommentare.
Und auf unsere Rechnung an Anthropic.
Das wird toll. Wow. Bis bald.
Bis bald.